hello and welcome to PlayStation granade
how that Devil aria it's been a while
since we added a new episode to our
series looking at free-to-play games on
ps4 that are exactly that free to play
no PS Plus no hidden costs well well
there are hidden costs these days with
bloody microtransactions but I'll call
them out as we see them okay I'll go
through the latest ten offerings which
you may have missed in this episode we
have a city builder an RPG a battle
royale outing a tactical shooter and a
few fighters but if nothing takes your
fancy on this list check out the
previous six videos in the series
hopefully there's something for everyone
so if you're ready let's do this have
you ever played the Diablo series did
you like it if you did and found the
upload to your favorite you may like to
try path of Exile a dungeon crawling
action RPG which is designed to consume
your life if it gets its hooks into you
path of Exile is easily a 100-hour game
the game itself uses tile sets which are
randomized to generate environments
meaning each dungeon and area has
numerous variations or possibilities
promoting replayability the game itself
doesn't look massively compelling if
you're not into this type of thing but
give it a chance the amount of character
management and development is the real
draw here and loot of course cuttle of
loot choosing a class such as a witch or
a ranger will dictate core attributes
like strength or intelligence then the
fun begins active skill abilities can be
adapted to tune your play style which
will be key when facing bosses of which
there are many the story and the endgame
content have been praised over the last
few years on PC and finally ps4 players
can see what all the fuss is about
the only caveat to this free game is
that the multiplayer portion requires PS
Plus it's a shame but those are the
rules set before us if you've played
path of Exile and ps4 we'd love to know
your thoughts next up is a tactical
shooter on the sea world of warships
legends legends is the console version
of the PC game but this one has been
rebuilt from the ground up the seabed up
to work on ps4 the premise remains the
same sink the opponents battleships and
enjoy the spoils of war
I've been playing this one for a while
and I have to say playing with friends
makes this one even better a division of
three mates can be sent out together
alongside other players from around the
world and don't worry there's no ps+
needed here at all free to play all the
way I've made a beginners video about
world of warships legends so I'll link
it now if you're interested I think to
note is that planning and knowledge of
vessels will come in very handy and if
you don't know your battleships from
your destroyers you will after playing
for a while I even now know what port
and starboard mean video games have
taught me something who to thought that
sticking on the theme of vehicular
carnage let's switch the heavily armored
ships for heavenly armored cars
this is switchblade set in the near
future when sport has become weaponized
the name switchblade relates to the
switch changing between weapons in a
frantic fight in fact the switch element
can be taken further when losing in a
battle switch cars with different
attributes adapt your tactics change
your play style to be one step ahead of
the opposition it's basically a MOBA a
battle arena with teams of five fighting
one another
destroying generators before taking down
the enemy bases during each game you'll
earn credits or XP to buy weapons
in-game on-the-fly switchblade looks to
be trying to become an eSports and if
you played any game that wants a
professional audience chances are you've
encountered the trihard player base it's
too early to know if that will make
switchblade family-friendly are filled
with those people who swear at you in
Russian I haven't played much but it
seems quite casual at the moment but no
there are seasons and heavy emphasis on
ranking up if you've played it for
longer than 10 hours please give us your
insight in the comments the next game I
wanted to talk about now had me
massively excited dauntless an action
role-playing game in the same vein as
Monster Hunter crossed with the visuals
of something like fortnight our
overwatch sadly the April release has
been missed and the developers are now
looking towards summer release I have
hugely high hopes for dauntless and as
soon as I know more I'll let you know
let's look at defiance 2050 a massive
cooperative online shooter with skill
trees and other RPG elements we are
tasked with being an ark hunter in a
sci-fi universe theory
game was released in 2013 but the 2050
version has improved everything teaming
up with friends skill trees visuals time
and effort has been put into this MMO to
transport it into the modern era playing
with three other friends in a
four-person squad and then taking that
squad into a 64 versus 64 battlefield
ensures four frantic action the planets
are so big they can warrant vehicles too
the frame rate can be a little sketchy
at times and other technical issues too
but if you're a Loutre shooter fan and
looking for a game to play with your
friends without the need for PS plus
trait and let us know what you think ok
I know everyone and their dog knows
about the next game but it's never been
on a list here so I'm going to do it now
it's yet another battle royale murder
fest apex legends but it definitely
deserves a spot on the list over the
last few months
apex legends got so damn close to
fortnight crown and although as I write
this the numbers have dwindled slightly
apex legends is a masterpiece of game
design the ping system allowing us to
communicate with teammates without comms
is probably the most well known
innovation apex has brought to us all
but almost people want to know is is it
like fortnight or pub gee well apex it's
perfectly between them no building but
still enough personality and fantasy to
keep players interested for long periods
of time they do this through classes
with new classes added often and more
vanity items on the way it'll definitely
be interesting what apex legends does
next next up is a game that has been
available in North America since 2016
now it's finally out of initial beta
testing and we finally have access over
here in Europe this is big city stories
if you can't tell it's a city builder
crossed with open-world roaming elements
kind of like GTA meets Sim City you'll
be building your own town deciding where
to place each structure and helping the
inhabitants driving down the streets you
built is surprisingly satisfying the
problems arise though a few hours into
your experience when the predatory
microtransactions almost completely stop
progress we need gold coins to buy
quality structures and guess how the
game wants us to pay for those
yeah real life money we can grind and
work for things but something as small
as waiting for a new bunch of workers
can take six real-time hours the concept
is great but the execution needs a
little bit more work does this recent EU
release dates mean that they are still
working on it we shall see any players
in the US or Canada who've tried this
can you offer an opinion please next we
have a free final fantasy game
well it's Dissidia Final Fantasy NT free
edition man that's a long title the
first thing we need to say is that the
online portion the multiplayer element
is locked completely behind PS + so be
aware if that's your end game but what
the heck is Dissidia Final Fantasy NT
free edition man that's a long title
well the story follows on from the
previous titles but you know what there
is no point telling you about that
because the free version does not
include the story either yep
they are definitely playing it fast and
loose with the term free if you do have
PS plus you'll be able to play alongside
or against your friends online who have
the full game but only a few characters
will be available each week it's
essentially a three on three fighter
which is another one looking like an e
spot attempt to capture those serious
audiences for class types are available
with unique skills and summons without
PS plus you can play offline but that
really doesn't demonstrate the city is
full potential now this is a great game
war face there's always a preference
with FPS players ru Call of Duty or
battlefield
I was battlefield by the way but also
enjoyed the tempo and breakneck speed of
Call of Duty well war face tries it's
best to do exactly that the realism of
battlefield and the arcade nature of
Call of Duty it doesn't always go to
plan but for a free-to-play game it's
damn impressive four classes are
available such as the usual medic
designed to rest he mates and the three
other classes using specialized weapons
war face continues to iterate continue
to improve and only recently added 4k
support on console oh and if I've made
this game sound like a simple copy of
popular shooters know that there is
innovation here too one mechanic allows
your friend to boost you up a wall to
get the high ground which is unreachable
if your playing is a lone wolf another
mechanic
allows you to upgrade and adapt weapons
mid-game no need to jump into menus or
wait for the game to end very impressive
there's definitely a lot of work to be
done here before Warface is arrival to
the big guns but they're slowly doing
the right thing so keep an eye on them
at present 32 player battles are the
upper limit and if you've played it do
you recommend it let us know in the
comments and finally the last two games
I'm going to do together because they
are light versions of fighter games
Dead or Alive 6 core fighters and Dragon
Ball xenoverse to light these are most
definitely attempts to allow players to
try the game in the hopes that they'll
purchase the full experience both games
require ps+ to battle online but only
Dragon Ball allows access to the story
mode 5 episodes in fact which is quite
impressive
Dragon Ball also gives access to
in-depth character customization and the
MMO hub like an open-world to run around
in both games are fighters in their own
right
although Dead or Alive has arguably more
one-on-one fighting depth and bounty of
breasts the Dragon Ball has far more
content and breadth
now that's a sentence I never thought
I'd say light games never tend to offer
much a simple taster but enough to know
if you want to buy the full experience
so there we have it 10 more games that
come under the banner of free-to-play
some a legitimate most want your money
in microtransactions and some really
should not be classed as free-to-play
please let me know your thoughts we've
covered 73 games over the last year
what's been your favorite I bet I can
guess if a fortnight or warframe am i
right I'm Adam from Playstation grenade
it's been a pleasure I'll see you next
time
[Music]